ça fait des années maintenant que je
parle du smartphone pliable de samsung
samsung galaxy x galaxie ic samsung
galaxy nexus smartphones avec des écrans
pliables
c'est vraiment un produit qui va changer
la face du smartphone samsung galaxy
gloire en façade un écran de 4,6 pouces
et alexis folle c'est le smartphone
qu'on avait attendu en tout cas sous nom
samsung axes x pendant des années qui
sont ensuite appelés samsung galaxy s
mais qui en réalité s'appelle samsung
galaxy folle et aujourd'hui il est là il
est beau il est chaud présente le galaxy
folle je n'ai pris en main il ya
quelques mois je trouvais très
intéressant non qu'il soit effectivement
retiré pour des problèmes techniques
le galaxy folle est aujourd'hui de
retour et je suis très heureux parce que
j'ai la chance de l'avoir ici on va nous
faire le premier un boxing du premier
smartphone pliable et je pense que ça va
être un grand moment
[Musique]
non
cheechoo va directement dans un endroit
dans le sujet dans le but du sujet alors
on va commencer déjà comme ça car disent
pas si ça se voit bien vous avez bien le
galaxy qui est plié tout est dit on y va
comme ça de ce côté-là rien dans le dos
vous avez les informations galaxie fold
l'écran externe 4,6 pouces super amoled
hd plus l'écran intérieur principal
cette vague le 3 pouces dynamique à
molette toutes les infos sur les
appareils photos la mémoire externe est
compris entre assez cool on a une
version 512 giga ici pas grand chose et
en dessous je vous passe un petit peu
tous les trucs mais il est bien écrit
fabriquée en corée par samsung fierté
nationale je pense d'avoir ce smartphone
pliable certains de boxing qui est
vraiment particulier parce que ça fait
tellement longtemps que j'attends de
pouvoir tester un smartphone comme ça
alors là bon je t'ai déjà pris en main
il ya quelques temps je le connais la v2
en plus gelé vu à berlin il ya pas très
longtemps est enfin franchement je
continue vraiment aimé ce produit
vraiment la prise en main et sommes donc
là c'est la nouvelle charnière qui
permet effectivement d'éviter qu'il y
ait des petites particulier concerné qui
viennent de d'enquêté complètement
retravaillée pour ajouter en solidité en
durabilité une partie de l'écran qui
était pris pour des cons truction
l'écran qui a été complètement
retravaillée donc maintenant il ya plus
rien à enlever pour l arracher on a un
produit qui du coup on sera beaucoup
plus solide et voilà au moins n'aura pas
les le petit problème qui a eu avec la
v12 de ce nouveau donc c'est un
smartphone que je connais c'est pas tout
nouveau mais park east est tout nouveau
c'est packaging le format est différent
j'attendais vraiment s'il ya des
surprises à l'intérieur six ont vraiment
été chercher un truc un peu novateur
aller plus loin par rapport à ce qu'ils
font habituellement déjà sur des
smartphones très haut de gamme de
samsung vous avez beau packaging cnet il
est séché je pense que là dessus ça va
être vraiment sympa thiam qui touchait
la wine un volume qui ai fait ça si ça
se voit un peu le relief peut-être la
voyons sans et lettres on les touche sur
le côté on a bien le samsung galaxy
folle qui est bien écrit ici écrit que
d'un côté pas de l'autre ça vient comme
ça vient là ô mon petit lapin on voit
tout de suite l'écriture galaxie folle
alors si noir sur noir pas si vous voyez
bien on a le côté billets à bon là
dedans il n'y a plus rien ça vient
parents ont donc dire qu'on a encore une
ouverture comme ça vous fait penser un
peu aux poupées russes une boîte dans
une boîte dans une boîte on peut aller
loin comme ça dans cette boîte là ya en
face à l'arc de base y'a rien on arrive
on se sent le blanc c'est rigolo voyez
on est noir on est blanche pas si vous
voyez là c'est pareil
que s'y plier il ya même manière on a
une petite languette qui vous indiquent
il faut le lever comme ça et attention
et là il arrive ou maire rayés alors là
c'est cool nos conseils d'utilisation
là ils sont dit j'ai pas encore lu à mon
avis on dit alors on va bien expliqué ce
qu'il faut faire et pas faire pour
éviter les déconvenues
cet écran pliable mérite d'être
manipulés avec soin n'utilisait pas
d'objets pointus comme vos ongles un
stylo ou des clés et les incite pas de
pression excessive dessus quand vous
refermez votre galaxy faut y veiller à
ne pas laisser de cartes de pièces de
monnaie ou tout obligé sur l'écran au
risque de l'endommager
bien évidemment ça me paraît assez
logique votre galaxy phone n'est pas
résistant à l'eau et à la poussière à
nous exposer en aucun cas à quelconque
l'itil ça faut vraiment faire gaffe
il n'est pas résistant à l'eau et à la
poussière il faut pas exposé à
quelconque liquide
donc ça veut dire attention est ce que
ça veut dire attention s'il pleut si
vous êtes sous la pluie s'ils commencent
à pleuvoir vous risquez d'endommager oh
oui ou non sa demande et quelques
petites précisions
le film protecteur présent sur l'écran
intérieur qui est partie intégrante du
galaxy fold n'essayez pas d'ajouter un
autre film de protection sur cet écran
d'accord donc je pense que si on se dit
oh man un film de protection et cape
rouge enlevé on risque d'avoir les mêmes
déconvenues qui a eu au début sur la
baie en tout cas du galaxy folle c'est à
dire abîmé l'écran tout simplement pour
assurer sa fermeture votre galaxy folle
contient de puissants aimants garder les
cadeaux cartes de crédit d'accor
j'imagine au risque d'être démagnétisée
dispositifs médicaux implantables donc
les fesses maker et tout autre objet
craignant les champs magnétiques si vous
portez un dispositif médical implantable
consultez votre médecin avant
utilisation c'est quand même
relativement dommage que le pacemaker ne
marche plus que votre coeur s'arrête à
cause de notre galaxie folle mais en
tout cas c'est bien qui le marque moment
les choses sont claires et si
effectivement vous faites une de ses
erreurs en utilisant et bien je vende
bien évidemment pourra vous dire vous
étiez au courant vous avec l'attention
c'est de votre faute et pas de la nôtre
alors le smartphone là il ait
complètement ouvert donc qui n'a pas été
pliée à tous adorent ça c'est vraiment
moi je suis très fan je suis vraiment
très très fan du concept sous cette cool
alors où le testerai dans quelques jours
voilà c'est vraiment la première prise
en main l'onu coccyx enfin c'est le satu
la troisième prise en main parce que vu
en tout cas c'est une prise en main du
modèle neuf sermonne boxing et moi je
suis déjà très amoureux de l'autre cas
de cette typologie de produits à ben
alors à l'intérieur qu'est ce qu'on a
tous cas c'était cette partie là
maintenant on apprend le lever comme ça
ok
comment nous ont posés çà c'est toujours
un peu plus que poupées russes ça c'est
con qui est tous ces textes soit parce
qu'au final on ne peut pas lui lire
facilement obligé de l'enlever pour lire
ça c'est un peu dommage
le futur s'ouvre à vous découvrir notre
galaxie folle bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle ère qui va révolutionner la
manière dont vous interagissez
communique expérimentés chacun des
instants de votre vie avec ses couche
ultrafine de matériaux innovants offrant
une souplesse d'écran inégalée le galaxy
folle réinvente l'écran du smartphone
façonné à partir de matériaux et la
finition luxueuse
le galaxy folle présente un design
raffiné épuré qui vous permet de
bénéficier d'une expérience d'immersion
totale d'un simple geste découvrir votre
galaxy phone ok sympa c'est vrai qu'on
est sur un produit premium un hyper
hyper hyper hyper hyper haut de gamme à
plus de 2000 euros donc bon forcément
smartphone exceptionnel un service
d'exception parce que vous êtes des
pionniers à bravo là j'ai l'impression
d'être un des premiers américains qui
arrive qu'ils foulent le sol et qui part
accrue de l'ouest et que vous ne devez
pas vous poser de questions notre
galaxie fun s'accompagne d'un service
personnalisé afin de vous offrir la
meilleure expérience donc on à la
hotline la numérologue klein l'assurance
ça ne sont guère plus un an et toutes
les infos donc ça si c'est vachement
cool et là on arrive à l'intérieur donc
l'art qu'est ce qu'on a ici au cran ou
tir oi oi oi oi oi c'est vachement oui
qu'est ce qu'on a ici
voilà on ouvre ici à yes on a donc un
guide de prise en main rapide qui vous
expliquer comment ça marche comment
l'ouvrir toussa toussa toussa contenu du
coffre présentation de l'appareil charge
de la batterie installée une carte
nanosims connecter les galaxies bugs
donc on a pas mal de trucs ça c'est
intéressant comment transférer à des
contenus vers votre téléphone galaxy
bohec smart switch ça c'est un classique
à un bien neuf là dessus
régionales le guide gars en forme de
garanties ou qe jusque là tout va bien
et là vous avez votre coque de
protection qui je pense très importante
qui bien évidemment lisent mon deux
parties on vous explique comment
l'installer pour venir complètement
optimisé et protéger votre smartphone ça
c'est assez cool et ensuite à
l'intérieur de la boîte donc on a ici
son chargeur à regarder ce qu'on voit là
son bail à kg et là on a des petits bugs
ça c'est vachement cool on a quoi là
dedans on a le cas pour connecter en usb
c
marche ici qu'est ce qu'on a des petits
en bout pour les boyzone ça c'est cool
et à l'intérieur on reste ici un
adaptateur usb usb c'est ça aussi c'est
cool qu'il ya une vraie réflexion de
fait sur l'ouverture à plusieurs niveaux
le fait de l'ouvrir comme sade l'ouvrir
comme ça je trouve ça c'est marrant
c'est différent fait et en fait ça se
s'y prêtent vraiment parce que on a ce
format qui correspond vraiment aux
formats du smartphone donc quelque chose
qui pour le coup est vraiment différent
s'est pas mal passé assez marrant ça
revient comme ça ça se referme comme ça
c'est très différent de ce qu'on peut
trouver ailleurs c'est bien ce que c'est
un produit vraiment extrêmement
différents un produit qui est tout
nouveau tout neuf tout beau
maintenant on va le mettre à nu c'est là
une petite languette donc là ça vient de
derrière qui est au donc tout le message
sur 220 et voilà officines alors là déjà
il est tout neuf il n'a pas été pillée
et vous avez déjà la petite marque
l'assaut de choix contesté en usine si
j'avais à dire je sais pas si vous le
voyez bien je suis très loin de nous
montre un peu là là on va légèrement
l'appli dion en fête au centre ce qui
paraît quand même relativement normal
parce que ça il faut bien le prêt plier
un peu près sûr que le moment où
quelqu'un va le prendre et bien ça sera
un match complètement ça sera
parfaitement efficace donc là on as
lattes faisant suite au conflit
j'adore moi j'adore vraiment sommes
alors après le seul truc que je lui
reproche mais c'est normal on est sur un
smartphone c'est le début on est
vraiment sur le début de ce produit là
c'est que effectivement il est épais
mais ça me paraît aussi normal quand
vous le tenez comme ça l'était soeur
elle est complètement saoul logique
normale se pose pas de problème mais
c'est vrai qu'une fois replié voilà on
est sur un produit un peu épais à côté
sans blessure à un mollet qui est très
long facile alors très facile à utiliser
une main comme ça vous à votre petit
écran entre on va l'allumer 1 sur le
côté bon j'ai déjà regardé je vous déjà
montré lors de la première présentation
est prise en main moi j'aime bien je
trouve que c'est assez efficace je pense
là encore des choses à améliorer sur ce
produit il ya des choses à apporter pour
aller beaucoup plus loin c'est beaucoup
plus fermé ici que ici je sais pas si on
le voit bien il ya un petit écart mais
non c'est son adn il est comme ça ça me
pose pas de problème de l'usbc si le
micro vous avez si votre haut parleurs
sur l'eau vous avez le micro pour la
réduction de bruit vous avez je pense
ici aussi les haut parleurs on va se
tester sans mal le regard des
haut-parleurs sur la face caméra
extérieure vous avez deux caméras à
l'intérieur et vous avez trois caméras à
l'extérieur donc on en tout six caméras
on aller ici à la caméra que le samsung
galaxy se disent plus samsung galaxy
folle moi je suis vraiment heureux ça
faisait tellement longtemps que
j'attendais ce smartphone pour pouvoir
le tester
le boxer prendre du temps l'avoir avec
moi c'est l'un des rares smartphones que
j'ai pu prendre en main pendant une demi
heure et que j'avais absolument pas
envie de rendre je sais pas encore cette
encoches là je suis moyennement fans
mais bon voilà c'est le début mais
regardez-moi le confort ça c'est
vraiment un truc que je trouve
exceptionnel l'amf demande de m netflix
à jour pourra utiliser parce que
forcément vu le format utilisé en
tablette on va regarder plein de trucs
dessus ce qu'est ce qui est à présent
prononcer d'abord effectivement ces
boutons sur le côté j'ai l'habitude de
les avoir au centre donc là me retrouve
avec ça la bourse amf un petit peu
bizarre après côté de ça je trouve ça
vachement cool on parle la base le
smartphone est pliée fermé bouton pour
l'allumer bouton de volume capteur
d'empreintes digitales sortait bien fait
de faire un seul et même bouton capteur
d'empreintes digitales pourquoi pas je
me prends comme ça il est là je suis là
donc là je peux l'utiliser je dirais
soit android classique secousse de
luminosité à fond tac capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui est
extrêmement réactif ça c'est cool
alors ensuite j'ai quoi j'ai pas grand
chose téléphone plextor appareil photo
ça marche
là je vais retrouver mes applis je le
met une photo qu'on a fait avec quand un
autre jour et là normalement six jours
je dois avoir ma photo au milieu donc
l'asema faute au milieu
je trouve ça vachement cool sur le côté
là je vais récupérer mes trucs
calendrier toussa toussa toussa si
j'appuie la caisse que j'ai là j'ouvre
donc j'ai toutes mes applications pour
faire du multi fenêtres et là par
exemple je ne m j'en sais rien moi et
youtube hop j'ai dit tu vends multi
fenêtres
là je peux venir moduler l'espace deux
fenêtres et one eu à éponger toutes mes
infos un petit peu un petit peu standard
données biométriques mais compte bien
n'être numérique ça marche tout ça si
cool bon écoutez moi ce que je propose
c'est que je regarde tout ça vraiment en
détail on va le tester et on en reparle
dans quelques jours dernier point
important c'est lui mette la coque de
protection alors que ça c'est la caméra
avant je dois lacéré par le haut et
ensuite je pousse pas ça ça vient de
tirer sa 100ème c'est quoi ça a c'est
que ça vient de coller en fait
ok il ya une petite languette l'a pas si
vous les voyez là je prends je tire et
ça en fait ça tout cas un peu collant
donc je pense que ça vient vraiment pour
le coller un peu aux smartphones et que
ça ne bouge pas donc je le net par le
haut
je positionne bien normal voilà ça
marche je n'ai pas fait de l'autre côté
vous avez color la troupe arnaud là qui
va juste voilà comme ça au moins il est
protégé
il peut potentiellement rien lui arriver
je suis très très content de pouvoir
tester ce smartphone ça faisait
tellement longtemps qu'on parle des
smartphones à écran pliable tellement
longtemps que j'ai vu ce fol pour la
première fois j'ai tellement frustré que
ces problèmes et qu'ils doivent repartir
je suis très heureux de pouvoir avoir
c'est un smartphone qui m'a été prêté
par samsung que j'ai pendant quelques
jours et croyez moi je vais bien
utilisés je pense qu'on va bien se
marrer parce que ça c'est vraiment hypra
cool
a vous de me dire maintenant que ce que
vous en pensez comment vous trouvez ce
samsung galaxy folle ce qui peut vous
paraître intéressant qu'est ce que vous
pensez de la boîte du déballage et du
produit tel qu'il est là est ce que au
delà du prix et coûte très cher il est
vraiment pas destiné à beaucoup de
personnes
y'a pas beaucoup personnes qui ont posé
plus de 2000 euros pour un smartphone
même si c'est l'avenir c'est novateur
je reste persuadé que ça c'est l'avenir
du smartphone peut-être pas comme il est
là en l'état il va y avoir des
évolutions que nous aurons d'autres
l'année prochaine mais en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que c'est une nouvelle
ère c'est un nouveau truc ça c'est un
nouveau type de produit et qui est
vachement intéressante dites moi ce que
vous en pensez vous en bas aux
commentaires et quant à nous on se
retrouve très bientôt pour parler du
galaxy folle et croyez moi il ya plagiat
reçue je n'embrasse à demain ciao